attenzione i bossoli dove date stronzate
tipo questo ragazzo è non mi ha di più
oddio aspetta smetta c9 cruciali ferro
figlio del diavolo
oppure sono stati come me siete pronti a
tutto questo buona visione e lode roma
do sono sopra la montagna e proprio che
è che se cade a greco cos'è ti vedo che
tagli la bellissima yolanthe perché il
taglio l'albero e ciò vuol dire mai mi
sento dire dal gioco mi senti tu dal
gioco aspetta aspetta consentirà giallo
perché ci aveva acceso questo guarda
premi cure
[Risate]
oddio guarda dietro a guardare ed ha
scassato tutto
[Musica]
vabbè allora è qui no non ci sto a
crederci anche in mano gadget ha
comunque alla pro parlare adesso siamo
pro questa ti senti a ok quindi ce vole
chi torna bellissimo dell'anno le tende
del cazzo ti vuoi il casinò dell'ikea
che stavi tua prima che se stesso quella
casa gigante carmela lenarda porta 80
perché c è appreso delle gambe di di
uomo o dieci bambini no ne offre dai da
magna anche se non c'è più a casa
ma no non mi viene in mente istituto
ronchi che c'è tre moto non si chiama 89
tronchi c'è chi chiamerà falsa casa ci
hai messo una vita e ne hai capito qual
è il problema per così nell'idea per
montarla casa sosta cucina un coniglio a
perché tu sai che ti entrano gli animali
dentro anche se ci sia anche perché quel
recinto questo che vi di bianco aver
finto giusto metti che io qui ho messo
un po di roba da mangiare mangia non è
ray grazie no vabbè si bellissimo cos'è
sta roba
c'è la capanna sul no non è vero in
quanto la caccia era capanna ma non è
vero mai come adesso ci sale quando
insomma riuscito insieme a ex metta
oddio ci sei sotto terra dio
speri uscito è un po e non è fisica
questo avrà vabbè ma come hai fatto ti
fa parte premi il tasto e ti fa partire
da sottoterra però in qualche modo
riesce ad andare su no ma è bellissimo
ah è vero che siamo sotto scelta perché
è che tipo di gillet ma che fai e la
cagnetta queste c'è poi dormire guarda
con la z possiamo dormire
non capisco che cosa serve al buco nella
capanna leo è delicata anche tu non lo
so ma gaga dentro e galliani eroe del
giorno e perchè molè tipo minecraft
quando dormivi passa la notte dovremmo
andare ora foto del bambino abbiamo lo
stesso figlio ti amo con tutto sto
ragazzino
all'avventura già visto indigeni o cose
qui c'è una testa pesa questa poter
utilizzare l'ha visto che non faccio
sesso da due settimane c'era una
crocchia trio vieni dovevamo andare
nella classica non a caso quindi legge
se non sbaglio era di qua eccolo cos'è
che non so che aveva addosso
oddio ci stanno dentro il preludio di
una caverna la caverna si conoscevano
più solo di fuori una governance io
corri corri centro come ricordo è il
dragone ragone con e veloce 8 eccoti
eccoti già buio dentro questi non è e
non entrano per chies obesi e non ci
passano da una fessura di loro si
sentono ne famo culo quindi non è in
tasca se se ne andiamo versione nelle
grotte che che ci sta e nelle grotte ci
stanno i tipi o una valigia sia carpisa
ha guardato cioè di massa dormendo
sandro mail order mano così come cavalli
esatto non sanno montare i letti quindi
si arrangiano
ma se io ma basso loro non mi vedono non
dovrebbero svegliarsi ma che come gli
spari nguema scandiamo 2 ei buongiorno
giorno si gioca gocce le grazie a
camorino reso morto come ora come arrivo
io ma questo e ninja è stato è morto è
morto è morto sono le voglio ammazzati
tante braccia io devo bere non siamo
bene la io devo speck e forse ho trovato
o perfetto che si vede di più perché
sono si vede un cazzo ora anzi dovremmo
essere a posto andiamo avanti in seguito
al carroccio il vino faccio la doppia
luce emilia l'uomo torcia madonna non
scarichino con che faccia triste l'hai
detta scarico
perché ci sono i soldi qua dirsi che
dire più di gente dalla destra un bocca
col fuoco a caso il fuoco di rho
l'onesto fuori insomma rispetto pieno
veramente la gente ce l'hanno solo il
dolore vedo tutto può accadere andate
via feticista mica stai morendo la
aspetta che faccio io il culetto non
hanno tenuto in una mazza non sono così
morto via via via via via più chiare che
ripiega ripiega cazzo no perché allora
io sono così morto però forse sopravvivo
in uno sempre morto non so come ma forse
riesco a il tu sei fuori
vogliamo ok sono vi così riuscito a
sopravvivere non so come atti possono
animare fermo e si è appunto o eccoti ok
ci siamo quanta vita i pochissimi
rimasto niente come l'altra vediamo
porca [ __ ] io so niente praticamente sì
o cazzate vita però cioè masticate cosa
è la plastic ha una pasticca the moment
minchia come larino scampata zio ma
proprio per culo è oddio scappata
parolone eh sì prove non siamo morti ci
ho capito ace di successo perché ciò in
mano o moriamo bastardo schifoso lurido
proprio così a quota c'è un bambinello
come un bambinello ciminello 5
ecco lo vedi ma come cavolo morto è
morto e schifo bella faccia del
personaggio dove sembra propone pure
rileva che fa il turismo sessuale
e allora c'è una valigia amica meno
gravi problemi che resta ho trovato
l'energia ha lottato energia dove ce n'è
un altro acqua e prendi la tua
no io vorrei spegnere la vita provata
ok io nostra una pallina da tennis e un
club ma porca [ __ ] preso la pallina per
dai ha bisogno o di raffa che ho di
novara da fuoco ce la fa a palazzo in
qualcosa recco a ieri qua a dio la beta
il successo è in realtà quel petrolio
un altra via che non avevamo visto porca
[ __ ] che è un pipistrello mi sono
caricato in massa che allora belli ci
sto andando anche fuoco aspettano il
cazzo è morto uno da questa gente non
piano piano mi andare così quale non lo
toccano aspetta io farei prima una cosa
aspettarci ma è stata netta ma una
stretta allora voglio fa una cosa finì
così facendo poi dargli fuoco 09 si è
svegliato si è svegliato la star da solo
e non abbiamo via noiosi cielo vita
mica è morto grazie a dio mi dai un
happy meal snap i mil
ecco il quale stardoll o di ore 9 è
stato fatto sono stato io perdono non
voler cioè tipo una porta
oddio profondiamo e sfondiamo ma proprio
di sponda si può bocca di trento si buca
si fa dio dio
salve e mi dispiace che a stesso
dapporto superino addio non è un ragno è
un ragno e ho visto tipo una cosa a
forma di ragno qualcosa a forma di ragno
porca [ __ ] via via via via via via via
via via ha detto che a formare madonna
che brutta cosa vi ha lavorato in fiamme
a testa di cazzo non viene più bambino
aspetta aspetta c9
verro figlio del diavolo
al bar
ha tirato sul fuoco che di fatto è stato
di marca [ __ ] accordo ragazzi che
concludono il primo episodio della serie
di the forest con leonardo mi sono
divertito un po è il secondo episodio
ancora peggio quello il problema
volevo fermarmi in attivino ragazzi per
ringraziarvi perché proprio oggi abbiamo
raggiunto il traguardo di 2 milioni e
mezzo di iscritti quindi grazie grazie
grazie di cuore ragazzi grazie davvero
domani ragazzi ci sarà il primo dei due
video speciali che ci saranno per il
traguardo raggiunto che come sapete
ragazzi se il vino è piaciuto lasciato
un commento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come nei video
totale descrizione di sky ci picchiavano
così ho vinto dai ragazzi